first of all can you give me an update
on on
how israel is dealing with the the
coronavirus
crisis thank you for having me we're
right now
i have this uh picture of two racing
cars in a car race
one is definitely the vaccine we are
moving forward
very fast we already have more than a
million and a half israelis vaccinated
throughout the country the vast majority
of them are people over 60
that was our criteria uh among those who
are
under 60 there are medical teams police
officers
the first responders and so on and so
forth on the other hand unfortunately i
have
to say that we are part
of this whole outburst of the disease
again and we have
numbers that are really terrible in the
last couple of days we have about
8 000 new cases every day
and just to remind our viewers that
we are a country of 9 million people so
the numbers are really huge
give us a sense if you can about how you
have managed to roll out the vaccine
program so
quickly you are the envy of the world at
the moment um
countries are staggered at how fast
israel
has got shots into people's arms have
you done it you know it's not a system
as we see in some countries of a huge
stadium with
hundreds of booths there people
sometimes have difficulty especially
when we're talking about the elderly to
get there
in this case they it's nearly
a door delivery for many of them i'm
slightly exaggerating but it's close to
it
part of the problem used to be that
the sets of the vaccine are a thousand
vaccines
uh that that's what we got from kaiser
we were managed through
israeli technology to split it into
smaller
sets with pfizer approval so now
sometimes our paramedics or nurses are
able to travel with a set of 50 to a
very distant point without wasting one
single shot
when do you expect that you will have
the whole population or enough of the
population vaccinated
to be able to return life to normal
very much it depends on the response of
the population
so what are you saying maybe by by april
by may
april is pretty realistic for this kind
of a number
but uh it will depend a lot on
no offensement but what is referred to
as british
mutation we are suffering from it right
now
uh here and there is no reason
in the world to believe that the vaccine
is not
working vis-a-vis these new mutations
but it definitely influences the numbers
you believe that the rise in the spike
in cases in
israel is largely down to the british
mutation do you
i can't say largely due to but
uh we think this is part of the problem
we found cases here in israel
some of them by the way
directed straight to people coming from
from britain in the recent weeks
some of some of them people who have no
connection whatsoever to
to england or or traveling abroad or
anything of the kind so
unfortunately it's here we do have to
say for a fact that is here
when you were talking just now about the
vaccine you had a broad smile on your
face
you must be one of very few uh health
ministers around the wing governments
around the world
with a smile on their face at the moment
and what advice do you give
to countries around the world who are
really struggling
with the vaccination program
well first of all uh it's difficult to
smile broadly when we have these numbers
of newly infected so i
i guess half of my face is smiling the
other half is still
this still has a worried expression on
it but
uh in terms of the uh advice
i would say what i already mentioned
during our conversation
get out there don't don't put a huge
station in the middle of the of your
cabin
and wait for people to come especially
when you're talking about population
interest
try to get it out to if not to their
homes then at least to their
areas to their suburbs to their towns
probably
probably it will help many other
countries i spoke to some of my
colleagues including
including the british minister of health
i think that
every country can find resources in the
situation how to
use more and more people with the
vaccine to get
as close to the door of of those in need
of the vaccine as possible i want to
to ask you about the issue of the
palestinians because
clearly there has been some criticism of
israel
that it is rolling out the vaccine in
israel but in the west bank in gaza
and indeed i think you live in an
israeli
settlement in the west bank and yet
the palestinians do not have access to
vaccines why is that why are you not
helping them
well i think that we've been helping our
palestinian neighbors
from the very early stages of this
crisis
including medical equipment including
medicine including advice
including supplies uh i don't think that
there's
anyone in this country whatever his or
her views might be that can imagine that
i would
take a vaccine from the israeli citizen
and with all the good will give it to
our neighbors
uh if god willing we will get to the
situation where there will be
nearly no demand in this country we will
be able to share
but having said all that i'm very glad
to hear
information that the palestinians are
trying to take care of themselves
they i think also manage to strike some
agreements with different companies
we will be more than willing to share
our knowledge and to
share our experience with them as i've
said
as far as the vaccine itself is
concerned we have many requests from
many countries
we think it's quite natural to first and
foremost take care of our citizens
but to be clear um if you if there comes
a stage where
you have surplus vaccine then you will
be prepared
to help the palestinians on the other
side
we definitely will consider that but as
i've said i
sincerely hope that by that time at
least part of their population
will be vaccinated by different vaccines
that they are trying to purchase
if any other help will be needed we'll
offer